todavía continúa sin una solución sin
una resolución clara esta crisis
política desatada en argentina hay
reuniones permanentes del presidente con
los ministros más cercanos a él que no
forman parte del grupo que que se se
informó que puso a disposición del
presidente de la renuncia que son más
cercanos a la vicepresidenta cristina
fernández de kirchner no está claro
todavía si habrá efectivamente cambios
en el gabinete o cuáles serán una de las
informaciones más recientes que también
puede confirmar es que la vicepresidenta
dijo que ella no estaba pidiendo la
renuncia del ministro de economía martín
guzmán eso es algo que se lo dijo de
ella según la información que tenemos
por teléfono el propio al propio
ministro pero si es posible que haya
otros ministros que ya consideran que no
deben formar parte más del gobierno y
todavía como digo no hay definiciones
concretas hay muchas reuniones hay
muchas especulaciones y seguimos
esperando novedades en argentinas
concretas de cómo se va a resolver esta
crisis política